E
VAST RIGHT-WING CONSPIRACY.
HE STILL STUCK IN THE 90s.
BUT FIRST, WE ARE LESS THAN ONE
DAY AWAY FROM SIPPY CUP MEETINGS
WITH VLADIMIR PUTIN.
AND AHEAD OF THE SUMMIT, HE IS
TRASHY IN THE U.S., LAUGHING AT
JOE BIDEN.
VLADIMIR PUTIN IS A HOSTILE
ACTOR AND JOE IS RIGHT, HE'S A
MURDERER.
HE RUNS THIS COUNTRY LIKE A
MASSIVE CRIME SYNDICATE.
UNLIKE JOE, HUNTER, AND JOE'S
BROTHER, THE BIDEN FAMILY CAN
ACCEPT A LITTLE BIT MORE
RUTHLESS.
ANYWAY, LIKE MOST ORGANIZED
CRIMINALS, VLADIMIR ONLY
RESPONDS TO STRENGTH.
HE DOESN'T RESPOND TO WEAKNESS.
AND SO OBVIOUSLY, HE DOESN'T
RESPECT OR FEAR PRESIDENT SIPPY
CUP.
WHY SHOULD HE?
HUNTER BIDEN, THE ERA OF PEACE,
THEY ARE POLICIES HAVE BEEN
REPLACED WITH AMERICAN DEBT LAST
POLICIES.
JUST LAST MONTH, RUSSIAN ACTORS
WRECKED THE OIL AND GAS SUPPLY.
AND INEXPLICABLY GIVES A WAIVER
FOR PUTIN SO THEY CAN SUPPLY THE
LIFEBLOOD OF OUR WESTERN
EUROPEAN ALLIES ENERGY.
BIDEN'S APPEASEMENT STRATEGY IS
NOT THE ONLY THING AT PLAY HERE.
DURING JOE'S TRIP ABROAD, THE
ENTIRE WORLD SAW FIRSTHAND HOW
WEAK, HOW FRAIL, HOW CONFUSED,
AT WHAT A COGNITIVE STRUGGLE
MESS JOE REALLY IS.
ONE SKY NEWS AUSTRALIA HOST
ACTUALLY RAISING CONCERNS ABOUT
"JOE BIDEN'S MENTAL CAPACITY"
AFTER THIS VIDEO EMERGED OF HIM
AIMLESSLY WANDERING AROUND A
CAFE AND ENGLAND.
ONE "NEW YORK POST" HEADLINE
READ "BUMBLING BIDENS G7 NATO
PERFORMANCE ONLY BOOSTS U.S.
EURO FOES."
ANOTHER HEADLINE READS "MORE
EVIDENCE JOE BIDEN IS JUST NOT
WELL."
TRUE TO FORM COME HE GOT
COMPLETELY CONFUSED MIDSENTENCE
DURING A MEETING.
I DON'T KNOW WHAT TO EVEN TELL
YOU HE'S TRYING TO SAY HERE.
I'LL LET YOU DECIPHER.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> EUROPE IS OUR NATURAL
PARTNER.
AND THE RECENT AS WE ARE
COMMITTED TO THE SAME DEMOCRATIC
NORMS AND INSTITUTIONS AND THEY
ARE INCREASINGLY UNDER ATTACK.
AND WE HAVE SAID BEFORE, AND I
APOLOGIZE TO REPEAT -- OH, JAKE
SULLIVAN.
HE'S -- I'M LEAVING OUT A LOT OF
PEOPLE HERE.
I'M GOING TO GET IN TROUBLE.
BUT WE WILL GET BACK.
BUT, YOU KNOW, THERE'S A LOT IS
HAPPENING.
>> Sean: OKAY, WHY DOES THE
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED STATES
CONSTANTLY LIVE IN A STATE OF
FURY -- SHE'S GOING TO GET IN
TROUBLE.
I NEED TO REMIND YOU EVERY HOUR
OF EVERY DAY, I WILL BE GLAD TO.
THIS TRIP HAS BEEN AN UTTER
TRAIN WRECK.
FRANKLY, I FIND IT EMBARRASSING.
AND IT'S ALL THAT DR. FIRST LADY
JOE BIDEN CAN DO TO TRY TO KEEP
JOEY IN LINE.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> YOU CAN SIT DOWN.
I DON'T WANT YOU TO STAND.
[LAUGHTER]
JOE, PAY ATTENTION.
>> HOW ARE YOUR MEETINGS GOING
MR. PRESIDENT?
>> VERY WELL.
[LAUGHTER]
>> Sean: JOEY, PAY ATTENTION.
OKAY.
JOE, YOU ARE THE PRESIDENT.
YOU DON'T NEED PERMISSION.
AND YOU'VE GOT TO FOCUS AS
PRESIDENT.
IF YOU TRY REALLY HARD, YOU
MIGHT DO BETTER.
BUT I'M SURE TOMORROW'S MEETING
WITH THE HOSTILE REGIME THUG OF
RUSSIA KNOWN AS
VLADIMIR PUTIN -- I'M SURE THIS
IS JUST GOING TO GO GREAT.
AND IN CASE YOU NEED MORE
EVIDENCE TO DECIDE WHETHER OR
NOT JOE IS UP TO THE TASK, WE
REPORT WE LET YOU DECIPHER FOR
YOURSELF.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> VLADIMIR PUTIN LAUGHED AT THE
SUGGESTION THAT YOU HAD CALLED
HIM A KILLER.
IS THAT STILL YOUR BELIEF THAT
HE IS A KILLER?
>> [LAUGHS]
CAN ANSWER THE FIRST QUESTION?
I'M LAUGHING TOO.
WILL LOOK, HE HAS MADE CLEAR
THAT --
[CRICKETS]
THE ANSWER IS, I BELIEVE HE IS
IN THE PAST ACKNOWLEDGING THAT
THERE WERE CERTAIN THINGS THAT
HE WOULD DO OR DID DO.
>> Sean: 11,000 COME UP TO
1,000, 31,000, FOR 1,000 --
WHAT'S WITH THE SECOND PAUSE?
BY THE WAY, JOE BIDEN WAS THREE
HOURS LATE TO THAT PRESSER WHERE
HE ANSWERED QUESTIONS FROM JUST
FIVE PREAPPROVED REPORTERS.
WE HAVE NO IDEA JOE WAS THREE
HOURS LATE, THEY WANT TO GIVE US
AN ANSWER.
I DON'T KNOW, MAYBE HE DRANK HIS
MORE MILK EARLY AND TOOK A NAP,
I DON'T KNOW, NAPPY TIME.
WAS HE LOADING UP ON HIS
CONFIDENCE OF HIS BRAIN COULD
FUNCTION AS A HAVE WEIGHED
DECENT LEVEL?
WE HAVE NO IDEA.
IT'S OBVIOUS TO THE ENTIRE WORLD
WHY THERE IS NOT GOING TO BE A
JOINT PRESS CONFERENCE FOLLOWING
TOMORROW'S SUMMIT WITH BRUTON.
THE ADMINISTRATION IS SCARED TO
DEATH JOE WILL DEEPLY
EMBARRASSED HIMSELF AND THE
COUNTRY EVEN FURTHER AND
VLADIMIR WILL TAKE ADVANTAGE OF
JOE'S CLEAR COGNITIVE WEAKNESS.
AND CONSTANT STATE OF CONFUSION.
OF COURSE, WE ARE ALSO CONCERNED
SURROUNDING ZERO EXPERIENCE TO
HUNTER BIDEN.
HE'S THE GUY THAT COLLECTED
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS FROM THE
FIRST LADY OF MOSCOW.
THAT'S RIGHT, THE MAYOR OF
MOSCOW'S WIFE.
AND KAZAKHSTAN ALEC BURKS,
UKRAINE OLIGARCHS.
AGAIN, LISTEN CLOSELY.
ZERO EXPERIENCE HUNTER MADE
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS IN UKRAINE.
NO EXPERIENCE WHATSOEVER.
TONIGHT JOE ANNOUNCED UKRAINE IS
TOO CORRUPT TO JOIN NATO, BUT
NOT CORRUPT FOR HUNTER TO GET
PAID MILLIONS?
TAKE A LOOK.
>> UKRAINE WANTS A CLEAR YES OR
NO ON GETTING INTO THE NATO
MEMBERSHIP ACTION PLAN.
SO WHAT IS YOUR ANSWER?
>> DEPENDS ON WHETHER OR NOT
THEY MEET THE CRITERIA.
THE FACT IS THEY HAVE TO MEET
OTHER CRITERIA TO GET INTO THE
ACTION PLAN.
AND SO SCHOOL IS OUT ON THAT
QUESTION.
IT REMAINS TO BE SEEN.
>> Sean: LET US GET THIS
STRAIGHT.
PERFECT FOR THE BIDEN FAMILY
SYNDICATE.
ZERO EXPERIENCE HUNTER GETS PAID
MILLIONS.
ANY EXPERIENCE IN OIL, GAS,
ENERGY -- NO.
IMAGINE IF TRUMP WAS DOING THIS.
AND SPEAKING OF WHICH HUNTER
BIDEN HAS A NEW MONEYMAKING
SCHEME.
PRODUCED LAUNCHED A
CAREER AS AN ARTISTE,
APPARENTLY.
AND DESPITE ZERO PROFESSIONAL
EXPERIENCE, NO ART DEGREE,
HUNTER IS NOW SELLING HIS
PAINTINGS AT A TOP GALLERY IN
NEW YORK CITY.
HE EXPECTS TO COLLECT UP TO A
HALF A MILLION DOLLARS FOR EACH
MASTERPIECE.
MAYBE WE WILL CALL IT PORTRAITS
FORMER OR SOMETHING.
AND OF COURSE, ACCORDING TO THE
GALLERY, THE BUYERS WILL ALL
REMAIN ANONYMOUS.
WHO'S TRYING TO BUY FAVORITE
NOW?
IT SHOULD MAKE YOUR SKIN CRAWL.
TIME WILL TELL.
IT'S DISGUSTING AND IT'S
HAPPENING RIGHT IN FRONT OF OUR
EYES.
BUT APPARENTLY YOU ARE BIDEN,
THE RULES DON'T APPLY TO YOU.
YOU CAN LIE ON GUN APPLICATION,
YOU CAN SELL ACCESS TO THE
HIGH-RISK LEVELS OF OUR
GOVERNMENT.
YOU CAN TAKE AWAY THE CHILD'S
MOTHER'S HEALTH CARE IF YOU WERE
HUNTER.
YOU CAN EVEN SAY AT THE WORD.
AND IN THE CASE OF JOE, YOU CAN
OUTRIGHT LIE ON THREE OCCASIONS.
I'VE NEVER TALKED TO HUNTER
ABOUT HIS FOREIGN BUSINESS
DEALINGS, BUT WE HAVE WHICH WAS
OF HIM DINING WITH HIS FORMER
BUSINESS PARTNERS.
SO YES, IF YOU ARE BIDEN, YOU
CAN GET AWAY WITH ANYTHING.
THE DOORS ARE NOT GOING TO BE
KICKED IN, NOT AN EARLY MORNING
RAID WITH GUNS DRAWN.
YOU ARE NOT GOING TO GET
INTERROGATED FOR HOURS ON END.
YOU WANT TO BE THREATENED WITH
DECADES BEHIND BARS.
THE MEDIA WILL ALWAYS KEEP YOU
IN THEIR BIDEN PROTECTION
PROGRAM.
THERE WILL BE NO INVESTIGATION,
NO NEGATIVE COVERAGE, NOTHING
FOR THE SO-CALLED JOURNALIST AND
PRESS IS MORE THAN HAPPY TO
STICK THEIR HEADS IN THE SAND
WHILE OUR COUNTRY GOES STRAIGHT
TO HELL JUST BECAUSE THEY LIKE
JOE'S RADICAL NEW GREEN DEAL
SOCIALISM.
SO TOMORROW, EXPECT GLOWING
PRAISE FROM THE MEDIA MOB.
JOE WAS TOUGH WITH VLADIMIR.
IF HE WAS SO TOUGH, WHY WAS HE
STANDING NEXT TO VLADIMIR IN
FRONT OF THE WORLD AND SAYING IT
RIGHT TO HIS FACE AND